this is number three in my Sadler's
honest reviews in which I take a look at
books having to do with philosophy and
its applications to everyday life
personal development leadership and a
lot of other topics this time we have
stoicism and the Statehouse and old
philosophies serving a new idea by Pat
McGeehan and this is a particularly
interesting work because it is about
leadership in particular political
leadership and it's by somebody who is
serving in the West Virginia legislature
who served three terms there and who has
run for higher office unsuccessfully at
this point but really somebody who you
can say is is walking the walk that he's
he's writing about so I'm really looking
forward to telling you about about this
and I'll say a little bit upfront so
this was sent to me by Pat McGeehan I've
talked with him briefly about his book
and his work in a phone call interesting
work on the whole I would recommend it
there are a few things that I will say
about it towards the end that I did find
problematic but but yeah I'm a whole I
would say if you want to understand not
just stoicism in general but also how it
might apply to not only political
leadership but other cases where you
have to take stands quite often in in
situations of conflict I think this
could be a very useful book for the
average reader
I always like to begin by talking first
about the structure the style and a very
brief summary of the book so let's jump
right into talking first I think about
style it's well written I think that
it's it's very readable the the average
well-educated reader is going to
understand a lot of the references
McGeehan is pretty good at explaining
things through analogies to the the
present day so I think that on the whole
the style is is very conducive let's
talk about the structure so after a a
rather laudatory well there's
acknowledgments and then a laudatory
forward by by James
Aragon who is retired from the Air Force
there is an interesting preface here by
the author talking about how he wound up
getting into stoicism and how the
household that he grew up in was one
that stressed military duty and how
these these fit into each other so you
can tell this guy's already got an
affinity for home because of that and in
particular the person he's going to talk
about Cato part one is focused on well
there's there's an introduction actually
I should say and the introduction is
quite interesting because in it he's
framing stoicism in relation to the
other main you could say governing
philosophy that that runs throughout the
book McGeehan is clearly a libertarian
he's registered as a Republican but you
pretty much have to think of the
libertarian party is is very weak in
most of our states and looking at his
voting record he does seem to be a
fairly consistent libertarian not just
in terms of you know the right side of
libertarianism but also on the left side
he is a very strong advocate of personal
liberty NEAC stoicism as connected with
that so you're gonna find that discussed
in the introduction
then in the first part which is just
entitled stoicism it is fairly short
he's giving you kind of an overview of
yeah it's really only one - it's only
about 12 page 11 pages long he's giving
you an overview of some basic stoic
doctrines and a little bit of history of
ideas as well going along with that then
he's got a chronology you know sort of a
year-to-year set of dates that begin
with the death of Socrates and end with
Marcus Aurelius is death and then the
meditations later being released and a
lot of the other things in between part
two which I would say is really the bulk
of the book is a let's call it a
biography of Cato the younger a
political biography and an intellectual
biography as well Cato is not somebody
who actually wrote but there's a lot
written about him and what we see is is
mcgeehan situating Cato within the
context of the essentially the breakdown
of the Roman Republic a spanning uh you
know several generations so that's
that's the main part of the work and
then we actually get to the part that I
probably like the best which is entitled
stoic counsel subtitled applying the
classical method of moral conduct and
and what this consists in are twenty
little sub chapters each of which has a
title and then a quote either from
Epictetus from o Soniya source um some
other marcus aurelius or another stoic
and then McKeon's reflections on this
and applications or amplifications
sometimes as short is just two
paragraphs sometimes several pages in
length and then it concludes with a
listing a bibliography which is actually
quite long recommended sources
yeah that takes up well over 20 pages in
in the back so that is the the structure
and if I was going to give a summary in
in very brief I would say McGeehan
thinks that Cato is really the primary
stoic to look at in terms of how to
comport ourselves in relation to
contemporary politics and he's giving
you some some useful overviews and some
advice about how one might do that from
the perspective that that he is adopting
let's talk now about some of the key
ideas of this book so I would say that
if I had to pick just three of them it
would be Cato really is the guy and then
this contrast between statism and
individual liberty and then the
necessity of adherence to principle and
indeed first principles as McGeehan is
going to call it particularly in the
third part of the work so you know let's
talk about this this very laudatory
focus on Cato
I think Cato actually is somebody who in
in thinking about classical stoicism one
naturally does gravitate towards he he
had a very impressive character he was
consistent to the end he didn't write
things down instead he acted and so were
somewhat dependent on other reports
about him and I think McGeehan is pretty
even-handed in examining the record and
in addressing you know where there might
be misunderstandings of Kaito Kaito has
definitely looked at as the model for
the stoic in this this work then there's
this you know pervasive you could call
it theme of statism versus individual
liberty it's very pronounced in the
introduction to the work and I do have
to say that I think that McGeehan does a
fairly good job in in not skewing it too
far to the side of contemporary
libertarianism and you know remaining
within the stoic orbit let's call it but
it is definitely a stoicism that is is
influenced by this emphasis on Liberty
you're going to see that word over and
over and over again in this work and it
almost always means individual political
Liberty so that's that's a key idea as
well this notion about adherence to
principle this is another key concept
that McGeehan stresses over and over and
over again that one of the problems that
we that was going on within the
breakdown of Roman society and he thinks
within the breakdown and the political
processes within our own society is that
too many people first of all don't even
you know have a clear concept of what
principles they ought to have and then
when they do have them they're kind of
wishy-washy about them they don't fully
commit to those principles so they're
not really treating them as principles
and that brings me to another key theme
I would say which is you could you might
say principles or values are really
non-negotiable you you can't compromise
on them because once you start to
compromise they end up getting lost in
the process so it given that that point
of view it's very understandable why
Cato would be sort of the primary person
to look at in here another idea is is
that we have to cultivate the virtues
you know he talks about the classic four
cardinal virtues that that stoicism
advocated justice very important in a
political context prudence or practical
wisdom also very important courage which
doesn't just mean getting out there on
the battlefield but actually standing up
against being isolated
you know resisting in the face of what
you what you know to be wrong headedness
or ignorance and then finally temperance
he really does stress the importance of
temperance in here and and I think he
does so in a way that aligns well with
other treatments of temperance where
it's understood as almost like an it's a
good thing in itself but it's also very
instrumental in an enabling one to be
able to carry out these these other
functions that are that are necessary
for the states person for the politician
for the legislature for the leader
another key idea that is coming up is
the focus on character and and
discipline and this kind
flows out of the temperance and the
Justice and the courage part but there
is a very strong emphasis on developing
one's own character he's got some some
you know great advice here you know
resist personal ambition ignore the
chatter from others you know whereas
this one he's got a great one in here
about familiarizing yourself with
nonconformity and there's there's
another one in this this part don't
participate in trivial pleasures don't
don't give anything sort of a handle on
you one of the other things that I
thought was particularly interesting as
a theme in this book
both illustrated by Aikido and also
talked about by McGeehan as as something
that that applies to us in the you know
contemporary political sphere is you're
probably not going to make a lot of
friends and you're probably not going to
get power if you are actually a
consistent lover of Liberty on the one
hand or a consistent stoic on the other
hand or as McKeon thinks they go out you
know hand in hand literally if you're
that kind of person you're probably not
going to do that well in the political
climate and it's interesting to see this
advice coming from somebody who is in
fact immersed in the legislative process
who's managed to get himself in there
and not get himself you know booted out
but but who probably is a thorn in the
side of both both Republicans and
Democrats alike very much the way that
Cato himself was a thorn in the side of
pretty much every faction that was
around but he had grudging admiration at
least from from some of the people you
know I think one of the other key themes
that really shines through the biography
in that which really is like I said one
of the main portions of the work is that
Cato to the greatest extent and you know
perhaps Cicero to some extent is
well are really trying to you know hold
together the the Republic by by you know
fighting this this essentially lost
cause and you know there is no winning
horse to place your bet on you know
Caesar is clearly the wrong guy
he's power-hungry he's corrupt he is a
populist he's you know you know got all
sorts of unsavory practices going on
you know Crassus is not a good guy
either Pompey is not a particularly good
guy but they they do end up siding with
Pompey during the civil war but it's not
because they think that he's the you
know the best guy it's because you have
to choose some sort of side and this was
the least bad side and and I think that
that is one of the key themes that in
politics when you when you have to take
a position you're rarely going to find
one that that's totally congenial to you
and oftentimes you have to do you do
have to take the least bad side in a
conflict so those are some of the key
ideas of the work
what were the features of this work that
I particularly liked or found
interesting or valuable and also will
these be regarded as such by most
readers the answer to that I think is is
yes one of them is I do really like the
way the book is structured this you know
basic discussion of stoicism that
doesn't try to do too much then jumping
into this this long you know situation
of Cato within his own political context
and and you know telling a story
essentially then coming to some some
conclusions at the end that that would
be applicable in the present and still
inspired by stoic philosophy I think
that's a really great way to put this
book together and and I do like his
stress on Cato as the the central figure
and and I think that the handling of
Cato is quite good it's not just a hey
geography plate you know click Cato is
this wonderful guy who is perfect in
every way I don't think that's what's
going on here but and I do think that
that McGeehan is good at setting out how
the you know the maneuverings and
mechanics of the Roman political scene
were in effect breaking down and giving
way to to all sorts of interesting power
dynamics and opportunities and Cato zone
responds to that as as a stoic so I
thought I thought that was quite good
I think there's decent discussions in it
of the other key figures including you
know why some people think that they're
particularly good
I don't know that entirely by the thing
of you know all of these guys like
Caesar and Pompey are basically for
state power and Cato is somehow you know
a proto libertarian but you do learn a
good bit about each of the people
discussed in here and the complexity of
the conflicts it's not simply reduced to
a very schematic good guys versus bad
guys there's really a lot of guys sort
of competing with each other in in a
process that I think they don't fully
stand and they really can't get back on
track and then there's all you know the
personality conflicts and stuff like
that so good job in in discussing that I
think that another thing that I do like
about the work is it sets out a very
coherent bold perspective consistent I
think that this will be you know a
useful book for for people to take a
look at even people who have been
studying stoicism for a long time will
probably enjoy it I don't know that
they're gonna actually learn that much
from it but they probably will find it
interesting and enjoyable and I think
that people who are just getting
introduced to stoicism this could be
actually a good adjunct to reading some
of the other literature that's out there
because precisely because of its its
political dimension that it brings to
the fore so those are the good points
about the work
the aspects of the work that I find
problematic are pretty minor I would say
they might even be viewed by some as
merely quibbles but but I do think that
there are a few inaccuracies in some of
the story that that's being told and
it's not that surprising to me because
what we're dealing with here is kind of
a complicated intellectual history I
don't think that that McGeehan gets
Stoicism wrong as such but I think that
he gets some of the history of ideas
stuff wrong or or he just doesn't supply
things that they would be kind of useful
so you know for example he tells us that
the Stoics he essentially says basically
that the Stoics are coming up with the
cardinal virtues they divided virtues
into categories building the ladder
Christian framework for the four
cardinal virtues really I think the
plate nests deserve the the credit for
that I would say that the four cardinal
virtues I mean first of all Plato talks
about the four cardinal virtues right
you know Socrates have talked about
these but I think that historically
while stoicism did have an influence on
Christianity I think Neoplatonism
Platonism had a greater influence in
that respect there's kind of a strange
assertion about about Aristotelian ISM
saying that the Stoics are very much
Aristotelian asserting reality can be
determined through experience you know
Aristotle does have that that sort of
stance but this is not there this is not
where they actually do line up because
what they view is experience is quite
different again that's that's kind of an
epistemological quibble but but I do
think it's coming from somewhere I don't
really buy into the story that he's
telling about Plato and Aristotle and
stoicism in terms of politics and I'll
read a little bit of this Plato and
Aristotle had established political
theories stuck in the collectivist
Quagmire of the polis or Greek
city-state unable to move past their
status environment little distinction
was made between state and society
molded together the lack of separation
generally equated the two whereas the
state became society diverging from
these models stoicism treatment of the
individual enable the new way of thought
helping to throw off the mental shackles
of the state so that's a nice contrast
but I don't think that it really holds
up if you if you read Aristotle you know
read the politics read the rhetoric read
the nick of McCain ethics and I don't
really I don't really think it holds up
for for Plato as well I mean Aristotle
actually says none of the existing you
know constitutions meaning the
particular city-states actually are well
well structured here's how we might make
it better he gives you you know lots of
guidelines and then you know there's
there's kind of a claim a little bit
further on that the Stoics are really
the origin of the natural law tradition
and they are one major origin but so is
Aristotle again in the politics the
ethics and the rhetoric you you find
these discussions there which people
like Cicero would help to bring together
so I think that's a bit of a issue the
chronology I think was you know kind of
a good feature to have in there but
unfortunately it leaves off after
cruciferous succeeding clay anthems with
the the the history of the Stoics and it
doesn't talk about how the next goal
arcs are actually the ones to bring
stoic philosophy to Rome and and how you
know the Romans got introduced to it so
I think that's you know kind of a
problem there it's all about Roman
history at that point but but nothing
about the intersection with with
stoicism and then the modern references
like I mentioned there's about 20 pages
of references at the end you know it
just seems weird to me to include Thomas
Aquinas or Dante as modern references I
understand that that's opposed to
classical references and it you know I
would say there's just a lot of a lot of
books here and I don't know how useful
it is because none of its annotated so I
don't see that it's particularly helpful
but that's pretty much
so my parting thoughts on this book on
the whole I'd recommend it I think that
it's it's a good book to at least read
through if you're not particularly
interested in political dimensions
stoicism oven you might want to skip it
but if you are interested in the
intersection between stoicism and
society and politics particularly in the
present then I think you definitely want
to get this book you know the last thing
that I'll mention is I have you know a
much wider audience than just an
American audience and what we're talking
about here is an American legislator in
an American state talking about how
stoicism might fit into the system that
he's working in but but I think that the
principles that he's discussing at the
end would be useful for for anybody who
is thinking about you know a principled
way of doing politics in whatever system
they find themselves so it's not really
limited to just an American audience and
so on the whole I recommend the work and
I'd say I enjoyed it quite a bit
you